assalamualaikum greetings of peace how
you guys doing welcome to the deed show
and as you know we're in Spain and I'm
with dr. Laura Laura said o alaikum
Salaam how are you doctor fine so I'm
here because there's obviously a rich
history of Islam here in Spain and you
actually are Muslim and you are a native
here were born here in Barcelona
Barcelona you became a Muslim yeah how
long ago almost thirty years ago we want
to know why did you accept this love
well is a thing is a special travel for
every everybody for me it was a travel I
was a searcher a searcher in his patrol
items and at the end I found a woman
that did work with the body and through
the body we we go to the essence of
human being not through thoughts or
through emotion but through the bodies
with the most physical part of the way
through the movement of the body and
then she she she was because now is that
she was a Muslim and she invited me to
entered Islam me and my my wife so this
woman she invited you she shared she
shared the purpose of life with you
she sure your I mean your background
were you Christian what was your
background before there's Jim but not
practitioner there was I was deceived
the kind of practitioner here yeah
uh-huh
what are the some of the things that
stood out that stood out from the Koran
from Islam that pulled you in that
connected with your heart well I I had
that moment some children and and we
like that to meet them something when
way when I was was that how to how we we
we buried me
I was against and if a lot of things I'm
criticizing a lot of things in in
Western civilization but at the end when
I was when I will be dead
how will we we were it like a Christian
born at like Indian or Hindu no and then
this was a first step to and to give
them another kind of education
yes values but connected with
[Music]
completely realistic view of the human
being what do you think now and what
advice do you have for people who the
only kind of information they get about
Islam is through the media you've been
living in Salam for 30 years and now
does it hurt your heart when you see
this beautiful way of life that we know
promotes peace love just as so many
beautiful things a solution to mankind's
problems but then they turn on the media
and they see things crazy things and
they say oh this is Islam what happens
you know when you see this and what
would you like to tell to the people who
are tuning in and they coming to us to
learn my way to contract this is gives
my example without saying that I am
Muslim necessarily just lead to showing
a way of life a way of doing that is
different or that it has offered with by
the Western civilization so your
character Islam obviously the last and
final messenger sent to mankind Prophet
Mohammed he said I have not been sent
except to perfect good manners I lack
character of course that's built on the
pure monotheism of the worship of the
crater not the creation but then
focusing to be the best human being you
could be being good to your neighbor
being good to the humanity and large so
showing people by living that example I
want to thank you so much it's very nice
to meet people like yourself here in
Spain I came to see for myself and what
else would you like to say to the world
over there in America and Canada and
other places the world a message to them
what advice do you have for them to life
as a man as a human being you should
follow a model and if you you can't
choose a model or you if you don't
choose a model the model choose you that
is the the mainstream model economic
elites but if you choose the model you
choose your your
what they are searching for in your life
what do you reflect you about what do
you want to do in this life and then you
choose the models that you have them and
you will see if you compare that Islam
is one of the best if not the best one
Wow we're looking for gems of wisdom
look for the models but put Islam in
there and compare and see where its lime
stands and forget about what you've been
told all the prejudices and all of the
attacks and all the hype but if you're
serious sincerely seeking purpose and
you're looking for enlightenment do what
he said take the advice put Islam on the
table investigate it and do your
homework and sincerely genuinely ask
your Creator to guide you he will
facilitate a way Thank You Senor they
say Senora how you say brother Senor
thank you
we started with peace peace be with you
a Salaam alaikum